ja in der heutigen sitzung geht es um
den begriff des neides das ist ein sehr
interessantes phänomen was man als
emotion bezeichnen kann und was zum
ersten mal in dieser ganzen reihe von
emotionen die wir behandelt hatten
wirklich moralphilosoph relevant ist
bisher handelt es sich hier um zur
neutrale emotionen die man nicht so
genau moralisch bewerten konnte ekel zum
beispiel oder angst jetzt haben wir mit
einem klaren fall eine art moralische
moralisch qualifiziert waren emotionen
zu tun nämlich die einheit so und ich
zeige jetzt noch mal kurz diesen
gesamten seminarplan in der letzten
sitzung oben rechts mache ich wieder den
linken hatten wir die angst das phänomen
angst bei giga und heiliger heute geht
es um neid und eifersucht und ich werde
da ganz kurz eingehen auf crystal ist
und auf dem anerkannt das sind
bezugspunkt zur historischen dann in der
nächsten sitzung kommen wir noch mal
zurück auf satte diesmal aber auf sein
hauptwerk das sein und das nichts mit
diesen hauptzweck geht's um den hass und
in den letzten beiden sitzungen werden
uns dann mit ihrer mutter der liebe
befassen bei augustinus an abend und bei
harry für das ist wieder das seminar
plan so und jetzt beginne ich mitten in
das thema hineinzugehen nämlich das
problem des neides wenn sie mal genau
hinschauen sehen sie unten ein dateien
das zitat wie die horrenden monstrum
service imal festes also ersetzt der
neid ist ein schreckliches monster
schlimmer als die pest und sie könnten
sich denken zudem dieses bild ist für
peter beuge einem flämischen maler aus
dem sechzehnten jahrhundert und hier
wird eben allegorisch der neid
dargestellt wenn sie genau hinschauen
sehen sie hier unten schrift irgendwie
aalen sind gekennzeichnet durch eine
frau könnte man genauso gut durch einen
mann kennzeichnen
und diese frau diese person diese
offenbar neidischen personen zeigt auf
einem baum oder meine güte ich weiß also
wahrscheinlich eine pfote dieser
schnabel sie es ein bisschen gebogen und
jedenfalls hat diese frau oder dieses zu
vogel ein sehr schönes gefieder
das hat als auch etwas mit stolz zu tun
und man sieht hier die hier ist jemand
mit einer armbrust schießt jemand der
eine leiter hinauf geht also man könnte
das interpretieren als ob man dem den
erfolg nicht gönnen möchte etwas
sabotiert also das bietet anders für
viele gute interpretationen begehen auch
nach dem seminar nochmal genauer das 1 0
fürs erste ein ganz bekanntes bild und
ich dafür diesen zusammenhang darauf
hinweisen dass ich in einem anderen
sender aus dem jahr 2009 10 eine ganze
reihe von sitzungen zur phänomen des
unmoralischen angeboten haben dazu ihre
darunter auch zum leid und ich mache
oben rechts den link zu dieser sitzung
rein dann können sie die sitzungen sich
nachschauen unter prinzipiell
moralischen gesichtspunkten und nicht so
sehr unter emotions theoretischen
gesichtspunkten wie es in der heutigen
sitzung der fall sein soll wo hinter
sein das bild kann man sich stundenlang
vertiefen wollen wir wert sind ja jetzt
gibt es zudem leiht fragen worin besteht
die moralische problematik des neides
wie findest du deine emotionen welchen
kontexten steht neid welche rolle spielt
die selbsttäuschung knightley ist neid
semantisch und pragmatische fast das
bedeutet wie kann man die white logisch
modellieren das ja einem relation
zwischen verschiedenen regatta man sagt
verschiedenen positionen und wie kann
man den eignet da konkret vor
rekonstruieren logisch welche formen
verleiht gibt es das ist auch eine frage
die wir uns beschäftigen es war ja jetzt
komme ich gleich zu dem mann geht und
dort badet des neides also zum zoologe
und auch zur funktion die der neid
spielt
jetzt können sie sich mal verschiedene
fälle anschauen aber bereitet b also
person arbeitet also bbc es sei jetzt
die gegenstand des neides es ist ja
nicht immer konkret die person die man
beneidet weil die person ja aufgrund von
einer sache jetzt kann man also den
ersten fall so rekonstruieren mein
vorschlagen jeden fall zur diskussion
heißt der meinung dass bc nicht verdient
oder nur oder auch 10 verdient unser
wegen de
die ist jetzt die begründung ich glaube
eben dass wir den einzigen person ein
grund hat oder ein grund glaubt zu haben
für ihren eid denen sie gar nicht als
neid ansieht sind als einen gerechten
form von unmut geäußert wird anhand
einer ungerechten situation die als
solche behauptet wird jetzt kann man
sich diesen voller vorstellen tritt der
fall weiß dass sie gegen c beneidet geht
das und 4a satz ich beneide dich um ca
wir kennen alle die sprüche ich beneide
dich du wohnst in einem kühlschrank bei
32 grad ich beneide dich leiden wir die
person wirklich ist das wirklich der
sinn verleiht und sinne von missgunst
diesem schlimmen fall von dem video von
dem wir dieses bild kürzlich zahlen
ich glaube nicht als meine these der
zahlen das 3 und 4 mit 1 und 2 vor allem
mit zwei nicht kompatibel ist aber
darauf war man dann später noch genauer
eingehen
und fünftens einmal auf den fall könnt
bc das wäre in meinen augen genau das
gegenteil von 1 oder 2 also das
gegenteil von beiden scheint mir gerne
zu sein also neidlos anerkennen
so könnte man es auch so formulieren und
diese fälle wollen wir im folgenden noch
ein bisschen genauer hin
interne diskussion analysieren so jetzt
komme ich wieder auf einen positiven
artikel zu sprechen nämlich auf die
einen artikel zum thema energie also zu
englischen knight in den wohlbekannten
style von sigel ausfiel machte nach
unten in der beschreibung diesen link zu
dieser artikel eintrag hinein und jetzt
sagt die autorin folgendes nicht lesen
bevor
und jetzt überlegen sie sich noch mal
das was wir bisher gehört haben über
emotionen
hinsichtlich der frage ob neid eine
emotion ist die auto bin sagt henry sind
komplex und pasing in motion und tories
liegen die zinsen der karte kritischen
sieben toten dazu zählt auch dass
barrick kamen die charts must be right
to play universal in ein riesiges
ökonomisches auf rang 24
workstations brandursache kann die
trendigen den raschen alle tm 3.0
technik promotion explicit lyrics klotz
und wie in der vierten us kinocharts es
irritiert zum all das abgesperrte die
fans von chelsea entrüstet nws bjp geht
er ist kann silver corp
auf welches bis zu 40.000 einem etikett
bio auf der ces erwartet also kurz
gesagt die autorin kathrin these dass
neid eine sehr komplexe und verwirrende
form von emotionen ist und das
gewöhnlich die auffassung vertreten wird
das nein unhaltbar unrettbar schlecht
sei also unvernünftig und auch bösartig
und dass man zwar die ein versucht noch
in mandeln sind begründen oder wieso ich
sage rechtfertigen könnte beim night das
aber nicht der fall also die meisten
trennt sich schlecht zu sein
[Musik]
dies entspricht dieser artikel von los
angeles in motion wird es noch sehr
viele emotions agritubel morton felix
ist emotion pur ist cool dre und des wkt
station simulations and resorts feeling
motivations in baden events loosli
aufbaute
der gipfel in motion werbespot may not
be quiet element in das zentrum wo es
auf dem ocean spray bridgewaters dieses
element central casting motivation was
mir ganz wichtig erscheint das
fettgedruckte im ocean sun resorts felix
motivation als emotionen sind symptome
syndrom meint der laufen verschiedene
dimensionen oder strömungen zusammen
so muss man eine verzinkte unterscheiden
also so drohe sind komplexe
verquickungen von verschiedenen
tendenzen und das trifft auch gut auf
unsere bisherige arbeit definition von
den nutzern zu dass emotionen einen
kognitiven eine gefühlsmäßige oder
phänomenale und eine motivation ahlen
seite haben und so wird es ja auch
dargestellt und somit auch den leitern
genauer analysiert also wir müssen uns
fragen inwiefern hat der neid eine
rationale zeit ein gefühlsmäßige
phänomenaler zeit und eine motivation
eine seite vielleicht auch eine
körperliche gibt nämlich immer ein
bisschen zögerlich weil ich glaube dass
eben auch emotionen gibt die fast keine
körperliche zeit besitzen und so scheint
es mir gerade auch beim leiter fall zu
sein
lesen wir uns noch mal vielleicht ein
weiteres zitat durch das city kontos auf
dem ocean city of ember kontroversen wie
involviert ab örtlich
party who sent this media person group
of persons and some pro session possible
to have something that only one produkte
positiven doping-test go play einmal wie
samt ihres anteils hälfte beruhten die
hotelerbin ist ein koloss statements ab
q3 wmf der ferne tiefe differenzen der
prozesse bewusst will außerdem das wave
sollte die feinen wieder krieg
training ist vorm distress experience
touch die das neue opus esther good and
evil das in der thüringer desire for the
good to say that many but don't
typically in worauf sie dieser not have
thought this agreement ist explorer will
dann ist der verweis hier auf myvideo
cent liegen das sind diese zwei formen
kann
gutartige und bösartige neid und uns
interessiert jetzt vor allem die
bösartige weil dir noch viel spannender
isny wir gleich sehen werden
jetzt können wir mal hier ein bisschen
an die historischen positionen zu weit
uns vergegenwärtigen aristoteles flicken
gleich noch auf seinen text lautet
sprechen zeigt night ist ein schmerz am
guten glück oder guten zustand anderer
und kant zeit also das gut gehen andere
nicht dienen zu können
und hier haben also zwei sehr bedeutende
historische reputation bekommt erst
konto wales todes zu sprechen
ich zitiere was an der rhetorik die tat
die fragen worüber gegen wen und welche
gemütsverfassung leidet erledigen sie
gleich man fest dass der neidern ohne
lustgefühl ist über ein und in die augen
fallen des glückten betreff der oben
genannten güter von welchen die leute
unsers gleichen umgeben sie das gefühl
dass nicht auf den wunsch eine gute
dinge selbst zu besitzen sondern
lediglich gegen jenen besitzen den
personen gerichtet ist interessant ich
finde deine sehr viel entscheiden ist
schon drin nämlich dass es hier um die
vergleichbarkeit geht also das müssen
uns in einer gewissen vergleichbaren
situation befinden
um überhaupt eine andere person beneiden
zu können anderes beispiel
wir könnten jetzt zum beispiel nur
schwer gegen eiden um sein reichtum
warum weil wir zu wenig vergleichs
punkte haben aus denen wir eine
rechtfertigung basis für uns an leid der
uns als gerecht erscheint gewinnen
können das wäre für die allermeisten für
uns wir diskutieren heute geradezu
absurd wird es um sein vermögen zu
beneiden anders jetzt aus die nachbarn
der nachbar in dem wir uns viel besser
vergleichen können
mai dem finden sagte service weiter
werden demnach solche menschen dem
gewisse andere gleich gehen oder als
gleich viel erscheinen
zugleich stehen verstehen und mit zucker
verkauft auf mannschaft auf lebensalter
auf begabung auf vermögens umständen für
eine solche die nur weniges fehlt alles
stütze besitzen darum sind leute welche
einen großen wirkungskreis haben und dem
glück schoss sitzen neidisch denn sie
meinen immer jeder entschieden etwas
verdienen was eigentlich hingehöre
für diejenigen welche irgendeiner sache
ganz besonders geehrt werden zum halbe
in ihrer weisheit und ihres glücks und
zwar sind die ihr geld sie neidisch als
die ihr ganz lassen deswegen das gleiche
die welche nach den rufen der reise
trachten wenn sie sind eben ihr geld
sich nach anerkennung ihrer weisheit und
überhaupt alle nach ansehen und geld und
das trachtenfest in dem was diese
spezialität betrifft neidisch endlich
alle kleinen sälen denn gm kommt alles
groß vor was die gegenstände des neides
anklang zeigt aristoteles bereits gesagt
dass es die güter sind denn alle und
jede verrichtung oder besitztümer worin
man seine ehre und sei darum sucht und
worin man gern als ausgezeichnet gelten
möchte gerne alles das und das gebiet
die clubs gaben gehört ist auch in der
regel sammlung zu einer des gegenstandes
beides zum halt alles was man in jeder
selbst kann und möchte oder wenn man
glaubt dass man es von rechtswegen haben
ist oder worin mit dem anderen nur wenig
überlegen sind immer wenig hinter gisin
zurück stehen als ganz interessant
halten hier das dass man glaubt dass man
es von rechtswegen haben müsste dann
fühlt sich also gerechtfertigt in seinem
leid und würde wohl nie sagen dass man
jetzt die andere person bekleidet
mai bereiten heißt ja zu unrecht die
andere person zu unrecht die anderen
personen entlassen zu können
die person die etwas beneidet die
neidisch es wird immer sagen nein ich
bin doch gerechtfertigt meiner
einschätzung dass das der an- und person
nicht geführt sondern wir
darüber wollen wir dann noch genau das
cathin ich mache ein bisschen weiter
jetzt komme ich noch zu kalt über den
gehalt nur ein paar zitate der night
live als hand das wohl anderer mit
schmerz wahrnehmen
obzwar dem seinigen dadurch kein abbruch
geschieht der wenn er zur tat jenes
wollte schneller ausstellt
qualifizierter neid sonst aber nur
missgunst im wie denn zwar ist ist doch
eine in deren bösartige xi nämlich ein
unwille unser eigen wohl durch das wohl
andere in den schatten gestellt system
weil wir den maßstab desselben nicht
indessen immer wirksam nur in der
vergleiche mit dem wohl anderer zu
schätzen und diese schätzung
zuversichtlich bist daher spricht man
auch wohl von einer beschneidung würde
ihn eintrat und seligkeit in einer ehe
familie und so weiter
gleich als ob es in manchen fällen
erlaubt wäre jemand sein
die regungen des landes liegt als in der
natur des menschen und nur der ausdruck
derselben macht sie zu den
scheußlichsten laster einer cremigen die
selbst folternden und auf zerstörung des
kriegs anderer wenigstens die wunsch
nachrichten leidenschaft ist ein team
der pflicht des menschen geben sich
selbst sowohl als die anderen
also kann spricht jetzt hier vom leid so
dass auch eine der schlimmsten
bösartigen gesinnungen ist das spricht
für ein halbes einbeziehung wir können
auch sagen einiges an einstellung und
ihr unten spricht von einem leidenschaft
es ist an der gefühlsmäßige das spricht
nicht von emotionen aber ich glaube die
einstellung zeigt hier die kognitive
dimension des neides und die
leidenschaft zeit dinge mit dem
gefühlswelt gefühlsmäßig dimension
ja da haben wir jetzt zwei sehr wichtige
positionen mal kurz zum unterschied
zwischen neid und eifersucht gehen wir
zurück auf diesen ist informatiker
relations die komplett angeles für die
sense ist ist dies alte stinker motion
wollen in gestik los angeles ab von
ihrem paypal-konto für allen neu delhi
interessen als die playstation 3
stellige relation bei diskeeper charity
konzert und jalousien wolf report ist
desertec benennt anderes personal logos
auf concerns prisoners of action
die ist los los los auf konzern shell
ist nur 30 cent wie population dieser
vorbereitung der diese gut kopiert
portico persons effekt denn die experten
circus of konzert ps3 ja also es hier
geht es jetzt um diese logische struktur
verleiht also eifersucht und neid sind
dreistellige relationen aber es geht im
grunde dann immer noch als anders
nämlich um das gerät die geliebte person
die man glaubt zu verlieren
der eifersucht sagt jedenfalls der
aufsatz artikeln und im night geht es um
den ehrung den rivalen
ich glaube dass das tendenziell stimmen
dadurch glauben muss ist als
vierstellige relation betrachten die
night nämlich personal beneidet person b
und c wegen die wir brauchen noch diese
begründung die damit ins spiel kommt und
das ist eigentlich wird führte relation
die hergestellt wird
darüber können wir gleich noch ein
bisschen reden es geht dann auch
unterschiede zwischen gutartigen und
schlecht artigem lightman ihre was
passiert eine station gebeten wie
englisch ist aber jedes form und hinein
in einem relativ gold mining bereich
entwickelte point offen ist angel ist
der fall klar es ist nur irgendwie ist
sie belasteten käse des titels tiefer
der terrorist mit andy wolf studies a
rival du musst mir gut aber das bin ein
ende das nasse display ist entweder mit
dieser kritik des westens zu bekannten
virtual desktop und ich kann mir das tut
es ist sind in question wollte charakter
offen und perücke genommen also die
frage ist gibt es überhaupt gutartigen
oder ist gut hd kann eigentlich ein
widerspruch in sich
ich glaube er ist ein widerspruch in
sich ich glaube gutartigen neid gibt es
nicht könnte aber sozusagen der neid
wenn er sich positiv entwickelt führt zu
einer art von motivation ist der
geleiteten person gleich zu tun aber ich
beneide ich sie ja nicht ich glaube
deswegen blockade gemeint ist eher eine
form geneigt zu gewinnen dann ist es
kein wie auch immer
darüber können wir gleich noch genau das
cathin so zum schluss noch über die
rationalität des neides ss manns aus den
branchen energie auf den magischen trick
währungsfonds news virtuelles zinkl
student reisewillige motions mit reha
gut von der person has been sitting in
the cradle of circumstances wurden die
burschen ist alkohol trotzdem ist es mit
altem system richte von weblication grid
mwst beweise insofern ist ohne stable to
crawl inference emotions des best natur
sowie hanau so viel es ist amtierender
transsib ende ist von paymorrow verkürzt
die nbs unterstützen
sense of self service pack ist die
menschen hier bitte zur nationalität im
sinne fast meine normativität gesprochen
also ist nicht sinnvoll
kurz gesagt ich glaube dass wir es so
keinen aufschluss über die rationalität
gewinnen können natürlich ist der neid
nichts anziehen fallen wir können aber
natürlich die gründe von light verstehen
ich glaube neid wird sofern ihr
interessant aus einer rationalen
perspektiven wenn wir darauf schauen mit
welchen begründungen strategie internet
person operiert das ist also dieses die
einem schema diese vierte relation das
heißt im neid denkt die neidische person
sehr viel und sie führt gründe an
die für ihre ziele sprechen und dafür
glaube ich die rationalität besonders
interessant die motivation aale
dimension gibt es auch noch andere 30
cent ist nennt weise bildet hier auf
andy murray die scrum independent und
weise bildet auf die action mit modem
ins weiße wird intern den support bei
der real fischen means to dance at which
they were the doors open sales dieses
interesse das ist ein ergebnis des
menschen und weise bildet die fmb world
ipv6 day software association of the
good wird die nächsten für das erklärte
motivationsschub situation mail benefiz
sieht also neid hat auch immer eine
motivation situation die darin besteht
eben der beleidigten person dieses gut
anzunehmen oder die person hier
zumindest gleich zu kommen oder sogar zu
übertreffen
das scheint eine gewisse triebs weder
eine gewisse antrieb eine motivation nun
diese emotion des landes zu sein
so jetzt sind wir auch am ende der
aufzeichnung ich gebe nur einen kurzen
ausblick auf die nächste sitzung es geht
um die hass der auch moralisch
problematisch ist anders als die ekligen
zahlt das buch gleich ein buch der hass
etwas was gerade auch in nächster zeit
wenn man von hass verbrechen und hate
speech spricht immer mehr in den fokus
geraten ist und wir behandeln die zarte
und sein buch dass er das nicht so ein
interessantes kapitel darüber zu finden
ist dann danke ich für die
aufmerksamkeit und wünsche allen
zuschauern zu schauen alles gute und bis
zur nächsten sitzung